nous sommes sur l'une des vidéos les
plus importantes de ma chaîne il y a
maintenant presque un an à heroes et moi
nous vous avions sorti notre première
véritable collaboration et c'était sur
infinity ward alors ça a été une
formidable expérience
mais ce que nous ne savions pas c'est
que cette vidéo elle est en quelque
sorte chambouler nos chaînes youtube une
énorme amitié s'est créée entre nous
deux et cette collaboration nous a
complètement lancé dans le mc eu je ne
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
réellement mais ça fait onze mois que
tous les deux on est sur le mc eu à fond
que nous vivons vraiment mc eu chaque
jour
mais le 24 avril une grosse page va se
tourner le mc eu arrive à son point
culminant suite à 11 années de
chronologie mais cette page va également
se tourner sur nos chaînes youtube
bientôt un an que noté horizon sur ce
qui est pour nous le film ultime et la
fin est proche pour rendre hommage à
cette première collaboration avec mon
gros aéronefs et la fin d'un chapitre
important sur nos chaînes youtube mais
aussi dans l'histoire du cinéma
techniquement pour fêter ce si je vous
conseille de lâcher votre plus gros
pouce bleus et à activer la cloche car
je vous souhaite la bienvenue dans le
trois théories ultime sur avengers 4
endgame
[Musique]
j'aimerais pour commencer cette vidéo
théorique sur avengers endgame parler du
rôle de captain marvel dans le film car
un nombre incalculable de questions
l'entourent et nous devons les élucider
déjà il faut que nous parlions de ses
pouvoirs captain marvel est clairement
pour moi une héroïne over tchité elle et
ise depuis infinity ward comme la plus
puissante des avengers et son film sur
son origin story n'y est pas allé de
main morte pour nous le prouver
carole des morts ce tiercé pouvoir du
tesseract soit la pierre de l'espace et
de ce qu'on sait elle peut voler à
travers l'univers détruire des vaisseaux
rien qu'avec son corps elle est
également chargée en énergie photons et
tout ça est dû à son accident suite à
l'explosion du moteur supraluminique
créé par marvel bref elle et tchité mais
pas au point de pouvoir vaincre et tués
est en hausse ce dernier possède
toujours les 6 pierre et son gant de
l'infini
malgré qu'il soit bien amoché ainsi que
son bras gauche dano ce qui d'ailleurs
possède toujours la pierre de l'espace
la pierre dont captain marvel tire ses
pouvoirs c'est déjà un premier point que
nous devons élucidées quelle intrigue
cela peut apporter au film il est clair
que carole suite à son aventure se
sentent très puissante son origin story
nous la montre rouler sur tous ses
ennemis et humilie même run and avec une
très grande facilité
suite à la scène post générique où nous
la voyons demander où est passée fiori
nous pouvons très vite comprendre que
captain marvel va vouloir venger son ami
et tout faire pour vaincre thanos ses
émotions vont prendre le dessus
néanmoins un déséquilibre énorme entre
elle et les autres avengers sans compter
tort un jour où la corde est présent et
risque de nuire à la cohésion des
équipes
j'aimerais justement qu'on amène la
problématique de bruce banner dans
infinity war hulk est très très puissant
il est même dit qu'il peut résister au
pouvoir du gant alors café marvel pour
résoudre ce problème est accentué la
montée en puissance de thanos ils ont
joué sur le conflit entre banner et hulk
afin que hulk après s'être fait
avoir décidé de ne plus sortir ils ont
nerf le personnage pour équilibrer le
film prof
hulk a donc du coup de fortes chances
d'apparaître dans une game mais je
laisserai l'ami aéronefs vous l'expliqué
dans son ultime théorie d'ailleurs airoh
tant qu'on parle de toi dans une de tes
vidéos tu avais parlé d'un liq à propos
de captain marvel et qui pourrait être
très intéressant évidemment un risque de
spoil peut être présents donc vous êtes
prévenus effectivement comme je l'avais
mentionné
il se pourrait que captain marvel veut y
retrouver thanos et même tenter le
fameux un contrat ce sera évidemment une
lourde défaite pour carole denver en
plus de perdre une partie de ses
pouvoirs suite à sa confrontation avec
le titan fou à vous d'y croire ou non
l'idée pourrait être bonne mais une
seconde possibilité existe une
possibilité qui me plairait énormément
rappelez-vous de wendat wendat a obtenu
ses pouvoirs par le biais d'expériences
sur la pierre de l'esprit c'est parce
qu'elle tire ses pouvoirs de cette
pierre que cette dernière a pu détruire
la pire de l'esprit si nous faisons le
lien avec captain marvel cette dernière
tire ses pouvoirs de la gemme de
l'espace je pense que vous avez compris
ma pensée carole aurait la possibilité
de détruire la pierre de l'espace dans
l'éventualité d'un potentiel retour en
arrière pour attraper les pierres avant
la noce néanmoins une autre
problématique existe les pierres
correspondent aussi singularité de
l'univers soit les lois naturelles qui
la composent
quelles conséquences pourrait avoir
cette action quant au rwanda a détruit
la pierre de l'esprit nous n'avons pas
vu ce que cela pouvait engendrer
car tanoh ses revenus immédiatement en
arrière via la pierre du temps mais il
se peut que détruire la pire de l'esprit
est effacé ses pouvoirs puisqu'elle en a
détruit la source
il se peut que ce soit la même chose
pour captain marvel si elle détruit la
pierre de l'espace cette dernière
pourrait subir une perte conséquente en
termes de puissance et malheureusement
je ne pense pas que ce soit une bonne
idée pour un personnage qui vient d'être
introduit dans le mc eu sans compter et
les conséquences que pourrait subir
l'univers à cause de cette destruction
bref mais un lien existera entre thanos
et carole denver ce par le biais de
cette pierre et nous en serons témoins
dans le film soyez en assurés il faut
néanmoins ne pas sous-estimer captain
marvel en continuant le rapprochement
avec wind à cette dernière est la seule
qui a su ralentir tanoh ce sens m toute
sa puissance
alors imaginez un seul instant carroll
qui elle aussi étire ses pouvoirs d'une
pierre de façon plus conséquente que
world a déchaîné face à la noce nous
avons tendance à l'oublier mais captain
marvel et isère la fin digne finity war
les plus précisément dans la scène post
générique du film elle est clairement
présenté comme l'élément de résolution
est le dernier espoir de l'univers en
bref carole denver ça va être très
importante dans endgame et tu fais bien
de le mentionner à héros captain marvel
possède d'autres atouts que la force
brute
depuis son origine story carole et sur
le front pour stopper la guerre entre
cris et scroll talos doit beaucoup à son
allié carole denver ce depuis qu'elle
lui a permis de retrouver sa famille ce
dernier a même connu nick fury durant
les péripéties du film il est tout à
fait possible que des skrulls ali à
carole pour vaincre thanos et a mené une
sorte de nouvelle armée en 20 ans elle a
dû en sauver des scroll même s'ils ont
diminué de moitié
mais pas que carole était une crise et
malgré la trahison qu'elle a subi un
lien les unit carole ne souhaite
d'ailleurs pas les éliminer ou se venger
de leur haine envers les scroll mais
veut stopper le conflit et remettre de
l'ordre sur allah
rappelez-vous de run and dans les
gardiens de la galaxie ce dernier
souhaite trahir thanos et prendre sa
place il devient donc l'ennemi de thanos
ainsi que l'écrit qui le suivaient
malgré sa mort il est fort possible
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de cris soit
toujours contre thanos et souhaite se
rebeller face à lui après tout la moitié
du peuple a été divisée en deux suite au
claquement de doigts
nous ignorons encore beaucoup de choses
sur ce qui s'est passé pendant les vingt
ans d'absence de carole et il est
probable que décrit s'allie à l'héroïne
ennemi commun oblige nous serions face à
une alliance skrull écrit guidé par
carole pour défaire anneaux ce qui
pourrait avoir une nouvelle armée après
tout celle du wakanda été décimée et
xala n'est plus là pour les diriger
enfin j'aimerais que nous terminions
toute cette théorie sur les pouvoirs
brut de captain marvel
je garde en tête que la jeune femme
possède des liens avec le chant
quantique et je ne pense pas me tromper
si j'ai bien compris en physique
l'énergie faute on fait partie de
l'énergie quantique comme un élément qui
la composent
ceux ci voudraient potentiellement dire
que carole pourrez voyager à travers la
dimension quantique sans aucun problème
par exemple et n'aurait pas besoin des
combinaisons des héros à la fin du
trailer
d'où son absence bref c'était un petit
point que je voulais amener passons à la
suite
droit enfin west nous menace tous
thanos sera bel et bien de retour dans
avengers endgame je pense que c'est une
surprise pour personne
cependant il est énormément a le sens
des thrillers et ceci perturbe beaucoup
le rôle du titan dans le dernier opus
des avengers est très dur à définir car
ce dernier a bien confirmé à doctor
strange eyefinity warcq après la
récupération des 6 pierre et son
claquement de doigts ils souhaiteraient
se reposer et voir un nouveau jour et
c'est là le paradoxe
thanos a gagné et a terminé sa quête il
n'y a aucune raison pour qu'il revienne
et pourtant avengers 3 s'est terminée
sur un thanos wil wheaton ce qui prouve
bien que le troisième opus des havanes
lors c'était d'une certaine manière
centré sur son personnage qu'il en sera
de même pour endgame justement marvel
s'est joué sur nos sentiments et nos
attentes et je vois à 1000km
l'entourloupe qu'on a subie dans
infinity ward thanos est un visionnaire
comme tony stark
il prévoit le futur et possède une
avance énorme sur tout le monde il sera
toujours autant dangereux danos est
apparu qu'une seule fois dans les
thrillers et encore nous n'avons vu que
son bras gauche qui tient normalement le
gant de l'infini ceci n'est pas anodin
car thanos a subi de lourdes
conséquences suite à son action et son
bras gauche a énormément été touché tout
comme le gant eh oui si le marvel
cinématiques l'universe prend le temps
de le souligner c'est que c'est
important ici cela renforce clairement
l'idée selon laquelle le titan fou est
affaibli néanmoins c'est tout ce qu'il
montre du titan si marvel garde si
secret thanos c'est pour effectivement
accentuer le fait que les avengers ne
peuvent pas juste le retrouver et lui
voler le gant qu'ils sont également seul
mais aussi que thanos cache quelque
chose
je reprends l'exemple de banner
décidément il va falloir que vous aviez
voir la vidéo d'aero bonheur est
également énormément gardé secret dans
les trailer on ne voit que très peu de
fois et c'est justement car marvel
souhaite garder des informations
secrètes je pense que vous avez deviné
l'idée bref nous ne savons rien sur la
noce à part qu'il se repose à l'abri de
tout le monde et qu'également il sera
équipé d'une très lourde épée
mais pourquoi cela cet ep était
apparemment teasé depuis infinity ward
méthane hausse n'en a pas eu besoin car
effectivement il possédait les pierres
et son gant donc pourquoi par est elle
seulement maintenant je pense
personnellement que thanos va moins
utiliser les pierres que dans infinity
boire ce dernier a conscience de
l'implication et de la nature des
pierres et que les manipuler à tout bout
de champ peuvent chambouler l'équilibré
de l'univers
thanos possède à la base un but sain et
veut seulement relancé la vie ce dernier
ne souhaite d'ailleurs pas tuer tout ce
qui bouge au contraire regardez comment
ils épargnent les avengers ou encore
tony car strange lui a proposé un marché
le titan fou n'est pas là pour semer la
zizanie mais restaurer l'univers quel
qu'en soit le prix pour en revenir à
l'utilisation son épée il est clair que
thanos ne possède plus qu'un seul but
aujourd'hui cacher les pierres pourquoi
prendra-t-il le risque de les utiliser
au risque de les perdre et donc
d'annuler tout ce qu'ils attachent v
rappelez vous comment il a failli tout
perdre dans infinity ward thanos est
très intelligent et ne se fera pas avoir
si facilement enfin j'aimerais revenir
sur la pierre de l'âme et donc du coup
gamme aura en effet pour ceux qui ne
savent pas gamme aura n'est pas
réellement considérer comme morte et
pour cause ces dernières est prisonnière
de la gemme de l'âme comme montré à la
fin d'une infiniti war thanos peut
toujours entrer en contact avec elle
de par son sacrifice et elle va avoir un
sacré rôle à jouer
si nous nous rappelons de la scène où
elle communique avec thanos gamme aura
lui fait la morale en lui affirmant
est-ce que tu l'as fait et combien ça a
coûté camorra est présente pour créer
des remords à thanos et jouer sur ses
sentiments
nous savons que le sacrifice de gamme
aura lui a coûté et la jeune femme sait
ce qu'elle doit faire
je pense qu'elle gardera même un rapport
avec la pierre de l'âme après endgame
nous en reparlerons dans une prochaine
vidéo mais il ya ici un moyen de faire
évoluer gamme aura en quelqu'un de plus
puissant
petite mention honorable à adam warlock
qui avait à la base ce rôle dans les
comics après tout il est bon de parfois
se rappeler des origines du mc eu
l'inspiration peut alors exister selon
différents niveaux
[Musique]
je joue
bien pour terminer cette vidéo nous
allons passer sur une note un peu plus
sombre comme vous le savez ngame signera
la fin de la phase iii du mc eu un gros
chapitre se tournent les trailer sont
d'ailleurs bien sombre et le film sera
certainement beaucoup moins drôle que
d'habitude chaque héros est prêt à tout
pour ramener les personnes disparues et
ce même s'ils doivent se sacrifier pour
ça je cite quel qu'en soit le prix
infinity ward était déjà très lourd en
terme de pertes sans même compter le
claquement de doigts en l'espace d'un
film nous avons perdu heimdall loki
vision et gamme aura même si gamme aura
voilà vous m'avez compris attendez vous
à ce que endgame soit limite encore plus
difficile sur ce point là nous sommes à
la fin du mc eu en quelque sorte son
point culminant marvel souhaite évoluer
et passer à la prochaine étape
cependant pour ça il faut que des têtes
tombent et notamment les trois piliers
des avengers
steve rodgers le leader des avengers
tony stark
le papa des avengers et thor le dieu du
tonnerre alors calmez vous je sais que
je suis dur ils ne sont pas forcément
obligé de tous mourir dans endgame mais
attendez vous à ce que des héros
disparaissent surtout eux il est clair
que si mme rogers commence à
s'essouffler le héros est de plus vieux
des avengers et il est présent depuis le
tout début de l'aventuré
steve est prêt à se sacrifier à
n'importe quel moment pour le bien de
tous endgame pourrait signer pour lui
une fin des plus honorables
qu'est-ce qui pourrait appuyer tout ça
déjà la présence importante de peggy
carter dans les trailers peggy apparaît
deux fois dans les trailers endgame la
première fois par le biais de la
boussole de steve et la seconde fois
avec des paroles provenant du soldat de
l'hiver tout en terminant sur la scène
de son enterrement
il est évident que la fin la plus douce
pour notre cher captain serait de
retrouver peggy dans le passé pour
terminer ses jours avec elle comme nous
montrait sa vision dans avengers de qui
il pourrait être prémonitoire comme
j'avais dit dans une précédente vidéo
dans tous les cas il ya de fortes
chances que steve nous quitte après
endgame ce dernier pourrait se sacrifier
pour donner la victoire aux avengers
comme un martyr
avec à la fin un enterrement des plus
honorables pour ne jamais oublier
captain america bizarrement crâne rouge
et dans infinity ward et peggy dans les
trailer in-game ce n'est pas pour vous
un signe que captain pourrez les
retrouver une dernière fois avant de
nous quitter
je le pense sincèrement nous avons
tendance à beaucoup trop l'oublier mais
tenez a été sauvé par dr strange car ils
représentent un élément clé dans son
plan des plus énigmatiques
il est clair que tony va vouloir sa
revanche et tout faire pour retourner la
situation
cependant iron man est clairement
l'avenger ce du début
celui qui symbolise toute la première
partie est lui aussi se doit de nous
quitter à un moment ou un autre
tony aura son importance dans in game
mais comme le montrent les traileurs
tony et sur sa dernière chance sur sa
dernière corde et est prêt à tout pour
vaincre thanos la fin la plus douce
serait qu'il reprenne le rôle de nick
fury et dirige le shield à sa place dans
tous les cas je pense que tony a pris
conscience des risques qu'il prend
depuis tout ce temps est au bord de la
mort tout ce qu'ils souhaitent c'est
retrouver peppers faut parer à steve
toni pourrait mourir d'une façon
différente
il possède un lien très spécial avec
thanos qu'il a reconnu et leur respecte
jusqu à même l'épargné le plus beau des
symboles serait que tony porte le coût
final et soit celui qui inversent le
processus du gant de l'infini pour ça
toni pourrait se sacrifier en effectuant
le snap finale qui ramènerait la moitié
de l'univers ou quelque chose du genre
mais les humains ne peuvent normalement
à manipuler le gant et les pierre
d'infini peut-être que tony trouverait
une alternative
enfin il faut que nous parlions de thor
soit le héros qui a le plus évolué
depuis le début il est clair que thor
est très dur à voir partir le héros
vient de se révéler plus puissant que
jamais sa nouvelle arme stormbreaker est
clairement l'une des armes les plus
puissantes du mcg
il va également retrouver walkyrie ainsi
que les derniers à ce gardien et fondera
une nouvelle cité je ne suis pas sûr que
thor doivent mourir
vu tout ce qu'il a encore à accomplir
mais pour passer clairement à la phase 4
le héros doit être mis de côté pour
laisser la place
il se peut que thor se sacrifie pour
défaire la noce ou plutôt qu'il s'exile
pour s'occuper de son peuple qui a
survécu thorn aurait pu lui pour
priorité de s'occuper de la terre mais
reprendre l'héritage dodin avec
potentiellement l'eau qui à ses côtés
tout est possible pour en finir avec les
avengers d'origine black widow pourrait
avoir un rôle plus secondaire en
s'occupant du shield par exemple comme
elle savait bien le faire dans black
panthères banner quant à lui deviendrait
enfin un héros avec un potentiel énorme
il évoluerait ou pourraient
potentiellement se retirer au côté de sa
bien-aimée natacha mais bon ça sera un
petit peu gâchée on va pas se le cacher
enfin j'en suis même plus que certains
aux cayes a pris conscience d'une chose
sa famille est plus importante que tout
et ne voudra plus jamais la perdre et
les top view ce que ce dernier va
vouloir se retirer de tout ça pour
profiter pleinement de ses enfants et sa
femme et donc arrêter les missions
secrètes qui durent des mois
personnellement en bonus je vois bien
que captain marvel prendre la place de
thor ou de captain america
la place de thor pour la puissance et
celle de captain pour le côté militaire
et leader docteur strange pourrait
prendre celle de tony techniquement de
par sa sagesse et son intelligence par
exemple reste à voir pour les autres
héros spider man en vieillissant peut
devenir également le nouveau tony
je pense qu and games va réellement mais
chamboulé c'est quand même un gros cap
de la chaîne depuis le temps qu'on en
parle mais c'est aussi également une
saga qui m'a permis de me faire
connaître
j'ai très peur de me faire avoir comme
dans infinity ward
car marvel est capable de tout donc il
faut voir toutes les options je suis
très heureux d'avoir pu faire cette
vidéo en compagnie de mon grand ami
aeros f à l'heure où je vous parle il a
également sorti une vidéo concernant une
game avec de bonnes grosses théorie qui
se complète avec les miennes d'ailleurs
les cent mille abonnés sont à portée de
main sur sa chaîne donc nous devons
aller l'aider à passer ce cap
je suis un réel passionné du mc eu et
j'espère que cette vidéo ne signera pas
à la fin de cette saga mythique sur la
chaîne ce 3 théo était vraiment très
important pour moi et je suis très
heureux qu'il puisse voir le jour
enfin si vous souhaitez que la chaîne
passe également à la phase 4
franchement n'hésitez pas à laisser
votre plus gros pouce bleus et à vous
abonner
let's go 64 vous pouvez me soutenir via
diverses plateformes comme youtube par
exemple ou tout simplement me suivre sur
twitter
[ __ ] j'ai pas envie que cette vidéo se
termine est ce que toi et rethoré par un
petit quelque chose à rajouter pour la
fin de vidéo alors premièrement
j'aimerais te remercie pour l'invitation
c'est toujours un plaisir de
t'accompagner pour une vidéo mon cher
hargrove ensuite très très important les
bilans abonnez-vous à la chaîne d'art
rock
il le mérite amplement je vous souhaite
que le meilleur laisse mercan c'était
votre dévoué argot rock pour le trois
théories ultime sur avengers endgame que
le liner soit avec vous et à jamais et
ce quel qu'en soit le prix
[Musique]